hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play lights and
shades now if you're confused it's not a
black screen actually took me a few
minutes is just sitting here and nothing
to realize oh there are options on the
sides here that's not really much help
because I can't even tell Oh what that
is because it's um spamming so much but
I tried to look at it I believe I know
the controls very well I'm not gonna
flash that at you so let's get into it
up any minute oh there we go okay ah
here we go
well this actually isn't much better I
haven't played this at all and I don't
know what it's about just wanting to
depict light sources if I don't want to
attract any attention I should probably
not use my light sources too much well
it's either one or the other because
right now I can't see a ding dong damn
thing oh there we go oh that's much
better
alright I was in some sort of tent in
the middle of the woods which always use
a good idea for horror games and/or
movies so it's kind of pixelated style
but this ask you something over there
but this game is on the unity engine
kind of the old trope of walking through
the woods but whatever okay I can sprint
indeed alright look good hello are you
important Can I grab you can I pick you
up do I have to use you Oh if there is
more of these candles around I better
find them all well uh oh it's gonna be
another collection style thing I see one
over there I don't know if I have a
sprint bar but I can jump and run so
that's nice I got that going for me is
that just lately different these mist
bottles are the only things that
oh wow excuse me
Oh phew me pardon me I didn't even
notice it okay so this is how this is
gonna be you're gonna be like that huh
well well well okay I'm ready just my
volume cuz I was quite loud there we go
where's the other leg oh it's a match or
a lighter why would I want to use that
that looks like ass I'm just gonna go
run and get these cannons what kind of
thing is just I know the game is called
lights and shades so I'm assuming that
it plays off of the whole lights and
shadows style of gaming meaning that's
gonna be really dark okay so I need to
avoid the diabolical monstrosity that
thing was big by the way I'm not
complimenting it it was kind of big all
right
so don't stand in one place for long and
use the mist bottles to keep the evil
things away got it
ready to play your game we're yet we're
yet buddy oh hello found another one of
you do daddy's got another one how do I
use it I think of the settings instead
three that doesn't help I can't see
anything I hear sounds and shapes and
noises in the woods huh come on come on
give me I can't stay in one spot for
long
come on oh okay alright moving forward
what am I supposed to do am I really
just supposed to collect these candles
and bottles in that bit it's very
slender esque that the low-res slender
come on bring it on just um just um for
me buddy pal friend diabolical
monstrosity all of the above okay kind
of I can't oh I can okay
oh no I've wait nope yeah I can't all
right I can only go up who's that ooh oh
those a treat I hear a sound I usually
do not like sounds that I hear cop I
keep getting stuck maybe cuz I'm walking
along the edge of this mountain here I
don't see any other points of light in
the distance that's usually how I found
the candles before but I'm not seeing
anything and I think I would because
kind of high up mmm
but I want to stand in one spot for too
long but yeah I don't see anything
maybe whoa ha another thing I threw the
thing at it didn't work yeah your remedy
don't work brick okay let's try this one
more time all right so I don't know how
many candles there are or anything at
all it's just exceptionally darkened
here strange dim your Spain's noises a
lot okay
I don't want to attract any attention
hello is it easier to see the candles if
it's pitch black I have no idea
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme another one
I think I'm following the same route
that I did before route route route
route route now the thing got me when I
was right here I don't know how either
maybe I should just maybe I should just
turn and run find one I don't see
another point of light not helping me a
lot game oh thank you I wanted no no no
no I went that way before I'm gonna go
this way now try to reach the valley
got me dating my intestines up my anus
yeah shut up buddy we all got problems
stop complaining about being eaten by a
monstrosity
I mean honestly who hasn't been devoured
by an evil monster in the middle of the
woods when we were camping by ourselves
honestly that being such a baby okay
this game actually is quite hard by the
way I can't last more than a few minutes
at a time that's and I couldn't run away
from that thing I didn't even have a
chance to turn around anyway find the
first one yah yah yah hey gimme gimme
gimme but the second one go below you
it's like two seconds you hear it and
you're dead
can anyone actually time that like is
that exact to think that's exactly two
seconds from the time I hear it to the
time I am dead it startles me makes me
heart all palpitation II come on bring
it bring it on you [ __ ] thank God
foot for your ass okay there's a first
one these are very hard to see because I
have a light like right here so it kind
of puts a glare on the screen so I mean
because these points of lights are so
tiny anyway oh there it is
yeah it is tiny you gotta begin me oh I
know what I need to do oh I'm an idiot
I've been wandering around with my
flashlight on it soon as I see a point
of light I should turn my light off and
then get it I guess or this game is
brutally hard it may it would make sense
where's that
get out of the way text you're covering
up now why are you where are you don't
see it can you please go away text
please look it it was here oh there it
is okay my light is off do not kill me
diabolical monster I don't have time for
your bull oh look it even shines when I
don't have my flashlight off gimme give
give yeah okay where's the other one
okay it's not just me right I don't see
a damn thing
I all it must've been hidden behind a
tree or something that is hard to see
I'm also doing considerably worse than I
was before god I can't even see if I'm
what am I saw I'm stuck on a tree okay
last light is off the only thing you
evil spirits away evil things evil
spirits mmm
can't see though it's just blackness I
don't want to walk in blackness Hey
I'm on a panic to bed there well I
didn't want to die so back off how about
Oh what is death
Oh God that thought going on here
what don't told me there was a house Oh
which the candle yeah but oh how is that
fair
oh that got me good you oh all right
it just realized to pray comes out of
nowhere I didn't even hear him like
usually there before there was a two
second warning there was no warning on
that one lose it there guess he doesn't
like me using like maybe maybe if I use
oh that's not candle that's a lighter
okay maybe I just use this one but work
out better I don't know seems a little
unfair
seems a little brutally unforgiving
maybe boo here I hear him I hear them I
hear him I hair him Hyrum does the other
one I swear you can't see him from a
certain distance you have to get close
enough to see it in the distance of
losing it
keep movin movin moving okay where did
where did I find the house I want to go
to that house I think I found it down
this way the right is a bit I'm not sure
uh where's it oh it was down in the
valley of the Gwangi loser gonna mirror
I was back I threw it through it
I threw the I threw the bottle they did
anything said where's that house where's
that house he held where's that house he
house it was here God dangus I don't
have oh oh what's this what is all this
thing cuz this what is that oh my oh
this is where I need to take them
oh I only have two oh how was I supposed
to know that
ah stop it stop it it's not like the
startling it's it's kinda Gary but I
mean it's more startling than anything
and I don't like being startled it mmm
top it okay now oh now I hear creaky
woods am I getting killed like instantly
see if I know the game doesn't want me
to use the light sources very much but
if I can't if I don't know where I'm
going then I'm kind of I'm kind of
screwed on now yeah the lights off I got
stuck okay
around left if I got good for there the
way see like after what ah
so I panicked a bit hey okay I get your
game I get your game though okay I got I
got boom I hear him I hear him
dear bye he's like right by me or
something he's like right behind me
yep I can't see anything
who is this fair good a candle or light
or whatever on no sucks cuz I can't see
where I'm going I'm going the wrong way
I need to go down to the valley that's
where everything is and I don't see
another candle don't see any other
candle okay okay if I turn my flashlight
off right as soon as I hear the noise
then huh oh oh oh that's with the bottle
it's the bottom that does not help me
you need to go down I keep thinking I'm
going down okay I don't know what this
game wants me to do I'm gonna give it
one more try because I think this is
unfair okay you know what it's unfair I
turn the light off
you get me I turn the light on you get
me it's ready to off but no I'm still a
dick see how this works
I'm not even gonna here's if I'm not
even gonna turn it on I'm not even gonna
turn it on and why am I not going am I
stuck on something no okay I hear him is
he gonna get me anyway
I'm stuck on something got dingus
ya see what I'm doing it's probably
incredibly boring for you guys to watch
because I can't you can't see anything a
little itty bittys burst of light a
small concentrated bird I haven't been
able to find more than two frickin
candles because I can't be big no it's
just a bottle a baby bottle because I'm
a big bubble blowing baby who couldn't
fight off one evil spirit go boom I see
Baba he's a little odd
all right do it I don't know how to do
it I don't wanna do it all right you
know I'm done cuz this just this ain't
working you know it ain't working so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching if you want to try to beat it
for yourself the length of the game is
in the description I can't
it's got dumpsters that's what I can say
about it but other than that I can't
beat it by one thank you all so much for
watching the game people what it is that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye
what is this cake from
keep out of wet hole
oh my god
god